[Music]
now first up is an update of an old
classic for today's couch bound teenage
gamer that's right it's called super
diabetic Mario Brothers
take a look
[Applause]
our next video game captures the
adrenaline rush of driving and using
your cell phone at the same time it's
Grand Theft Auto texting while driving
edition
[Music]
[Music]
you know very popular our football video
games like Madden people love all the
hard-hitting super tough action games
this new football game departs from that
formula
it's called NFL group therapy sometimes
I feel like every pass I throw is just
an act of aggression towards my father
you know I can never truly respected me
as a man nor did he give me the love
that I deserved man that's some heavy
stuff thank you sir
I wish you knew your father man never
met mine sometimes we can't see the
light through the long shadows that our
fathers cast
stay focused soon you'll be okay break
[Applause]
[Music]
they forgot to call a play though the
adventure games Skyrim was such a huge
massive hit it's made its makers have
created a sequel set in the world of a
popular in-flight catalog get ready to
enter the epic realm of SkyMall let's do
some shopping
that's good and buy it all right
touchless sensor toilet seat
that'll go great than the master bath
and breeze was this thing about keeps a
tissue box fell yeah that just makes
sense a doggy diaper man
find that we have an ultimate fighting
game that clearly has an underlying
storyline between its contestants its
UFC sexual tension like you like they
wanna dance workout just enough touch
you your god you're so smooth and you
know you're smoother let's take a break
take a break there you go does that feel
free
[Applause]